since there are so many people with
blood sugar issues pre-diabetic
diabetics and people with insulin
resistance i wanted to cover this very
important video on apple cider vinegar
if you're not doing apple cider vinegar
you definitely want to consider adding
that to what you eat even if you're not
doing keto or intermittent fasting there
are other things that can improve your
blood sugars that go beyond just
lowering your carb and
fasting apparently the acetic acid in
apple cider vinegar gives a very
potent anti-glycemic
effect
even if you're not doing keto
so in other words it can help buffer the
food that you eat
to bring things lower on the glycemic
index and help stabilize both blood
sugars and
insulin now check this out i'm going to
put all these studies down below there's
quite a few
when you add vinegar
to your rice let's say you're going to
do sushi right which i'm not
recommending eating rice but if you do
you will drop the glycemic index of that
rice by 35
which is fascinating if you add vinegar
to your cooked potato while it cools
down maybe on a salad or something you
will reduce the glycemic index of that
potato by 43 percent if you add vinegar
to your bread let's say you eat some
white bread you'll create a significant
decrease in blood sugars and insulin
again i'm not recommending this but
i mean this is this is fascinating if
you add vinegar to like eating cereal
barley of course you're not going to put
vinegar on your cereal bar but let's say
you had vinegar tablets for example you
could probably add that or orange juice
you can drop your blood sugars
and insulin and then there was a couple
interesting studies one was
consuming vinegar with sandwich i think
it was actually in capsules vinegar
capsules decrease the glycemic index by
30 percent and then if you're going to
eat a salad whether you add like
balsamic vinaigrette or apple cider
vinegar
as a part of your salad dressing you can
decrease the glycemic index by 31
so that is actually interesting that
goes beyond just lowering your carbs and
fasting
and anytime you lower your glucose
you're going to decrease insulin which
you're automatically going to reduce fat
on your liver you're going to lose some
weight maybe not a lot but by lowering
your blood sugars you will contribute to
weight loss you will also reduce your
hunger why because there's less
insulin and also you're going to have
less
cravings now i've done a lot of videos
on apple cider vinegar in fact i have
the highest viewed video on apple cider
vinegar out of all the videos on youtube
i think there's 14 million
views and one thing i want to mention
about what type of apple cider vinegar
to take i would recommend
the fairchild's organic apple cider
vinegar i have no affiliation i'm not
getting any kickbacks but most people do
the bragg organic apple cider vinegar
what they don't know is
somewhere along the line bragg started
to dilute their apple cider vinegar so
if you look at the back of the label
you'll see
apple cider vinegar with water but
fairchild's is not only organic but
there's no added water and they were the
main supplier
of bragg's apple cider vinegar i don't
know if they still are but they might be
so whether you're on keto or not you
want to add apple cider vinegar to your
diet if you have a history of insulin
resistance okay and have what's called
the dawn phenomena which your blood
sugars are high even though you did not
consume a lot of carbs the day before
and that is because the liver is making
a lot more sugar okay it's called
gluconeogenesis
and so people always want to know how to
lower the blood sugar in the morning
especially
well very simply you take two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar
before bed and i wouldn't take it just
straight i would put it in water i'd put
it in 8
to 10 ounces of water and so two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar equal
10 grams and i would take this before
bed because what's going to happen is
you're going to wake up and your blood
sugars are going to start to go lower
and lower and lower and the other thing
i'm going to recommend is start taking
apple cider vinegar before your meal
again in about 8 to 12 ounces of water
and of course you're drinking something
very very acidic so even though it's
diluted in the water you want to drink
it through a straw so this apple cider
vinegar is not exposed too much to your
teeth now there are other things that
can also buffer your meal as far as
reducing the effect
of this blood sugar situation we just
talked about vinegar but you can also
add fat
and fiber to help
lower this spike in blood sugar so for
more information about these additional
buffers you should check out this video
right here
you